dans un cadre exceptionnel les nouveaux
étudiants ingénieurs de l'université
pierre et marie curie vont avoir accès à
la rentrée prochaine à de nouveaux
bâtiments installés à saint cyr l'école
une plate forme d'ingénierie
expérimental pour réaliser des
expériences et des travaux de recherche
les métiers ce seront des métiers autour
de l'ingénierie 1 principalement on va
les retrouver dans des grands grands
grande industrie de l'automobile de
l'aéronautique du calcul du service les
étudiants pourront analyser avec une
soufflerie les forces qui s'exercent sur
les ailes d'un avion ils simuleront les
vibrations d'un immeuble en cas de
séisme ils auront aussi accès à cette
chambre électromagnétiques où on peut
analyser les ondes émises par les
téléphones
une pièce que peu d'universités possède
l'objectif est de reconstituer ce qu'on
appelle un environnement de référence
qui serait l'environnement des espaces
libres celui qu'on pourrait avoir si on
était
au milieu de l'espace avec absolument
aucun perturbateurs électromagnétiques
environnants certains s'orienteront vers
la robotique sur roues ou dans l'eau
avec ses mini sous marin capable de
s'orienter uniquement grâce à leur sonar
des robots guide et que l'on trouve déjà
sur de nombreux sites industriels
ça permet de savoir utiliser un sonar
disent bien savoir comment la plastique
marche
enfin parmi toutes les matières étudiées
les énergies propres et renouvelables
comme les panneaux solaires où l'on va
pouvoir mesurer les performances des
panneaux photovoltaïques sur une vraie
maison un site modernisé qui va
conforter la place de première
université française dans les domaines
de l'ingénierie la technologie et les
sciences informatiques
l'upm se hisse à la 4e place européenne
et à la 32e mondial